what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and I got a big old attack on
Titan history lesson here for you today
we are going to be covering around 2,000
years of history right up to the most
recent events in the manga so get
excited for that make sure to smash that
like button and subscribe for more
attack on Titan videos and of course
there will be spoilers in this video
you've been warned
just a quick note I'll be using BCE aka
before Common Era to refer to the years
before the Year Zero an attack on titan
and c ii AKA Common Era to refer to the
years after the Year Zero so for
instance when I say an event took place
in the year 300 BCE I mean it took place
five hundred years before the Year 200
CE it's pretty straightforward and
reflects the way we talk about our own
history in the real world now without
further ado let's jump into it 1003 BCE
the oldest event we can date back to is
when you mere for it's the first Titan
got her Titan powers in the year 817 see
II Grisha is told the Marlin version of
history by his father which says that
this happened 1820 years ago it's
currently the year 854 in the manga so
according to the Marlin version yamir
got her powers 1857 years ago it is
noteworthy that in the walls the royal
bloodline is believed to have been
unbroken for over 2,000 years the true
royal bloodline would have started with
the Emir so this event could have
happened around 2,000 years ago
Tom's aver also tells eek that the nine
Titans have existed for over 2,000 years
we can't be sure but this would be more
in alignment with the first chapters
titled to you 2,000 years from now for
instance it could be a message from the
first Titan Ymir's to Aaron another
possessor of the founding Titan anyways
there are three possible versions we are
given of how you mere fritz might have
got her power one is that it was a
god-given miracle and Aldi and
restorationist view one is that it was
given to her by the earth devil a Merlin
view the last one is actually came into
contact with the source of all living
matter an idea that is mentioned by
Krueger we cannot know for sure what
happened until Aaron or someone else
succeeds in accessing Ymir's memories
through the founding titan and conveys
those memories to us with the powers the
alien
creationists believe that yamir
cultivated the wastes built the roads
and erected bridges to span the
mountains in other words it was wealth
that yamir brought to mankind
she enriched the people and developed a
Content 990 BCE we are told that yamir
lived with the Titan power for thirteen
years before she died
after her death the Emir's soul was
split into nine titans who built the
empire of el dia el dia was a great and
ancient nation that destroyed marley the
previously dominant nation and came to
rule the continent more lions say that
this is when the Dark Ages began the
subjects of yamir who had gained the
power to turn into titans designated all
other peoples and races as inferior and
began to oppress them they stole away
their land and possessions wiping many
bloodlines out entirely Aldean's forced
other peoples to have their children so
that you Muir would have more subjects
this ethnic cleansing is said to have
lasted for 1700 years around 370 BCE it
was about 1200 years ago during el Diaz
rule when the tragedy of lago happened
within one day lago the big city of
marley was extinguished and by the
advancing titans the havoc of Monta and
the calamity of all unfolded and tens of
thousands of Marlins were killed by the
LDN Empire around the Year 240 C II
there was an epidemic that broke out
many people died and the world's
population sharply dropped but the
Empire of
aldia completely defeated the disease
not even one descendant of yamir died
the founding titan rewrote the
composition of the descendants of Ymir's
bodies in a way that was favorable to
the situation sometime during LDN rule
the Ackermann clan were also created
from fiddling with the subjects of yamir
they became the royal families sword and
shield and stayed close to LD as king
for generations 743 c ii eventually
according to our land version of history
LD s arrogance grew to know no limits
and the people of the once great nation
of Marlay began to plot against them
from within they were able to incite a
civil war weakening aldea not only that
they brought seven of the nine Titans
under their control and were victorious
in the great titan war that took place
about 100 years before the current of
of the manga key players in the war were
the great Marlon hero helos and the
Tiber family who successfully forced
even King fritz the ruler of the LD
Empire and the possessor of the founding
Titan to retreat to an island after the
war king fritz was left only with this
island he called Paradis where he built
three concentric walls in which he and
his people took refuge these walls were
built using tens of millions of colossal
Titans which were ready to crush the
world if anyone tries to interfere with
life on the island this is of course the
island on which our main story takes
place while these subjects of Amir were
doing this thing on the island life went
on in the continent some non Merlin
aliens remained we are told the king
abandoned them and left them behind on
the continent although some people
believed that it would have been fit for
more late to eradicate the subjects of
yamir the Marlon government showed them
mercy and gave them land they could live
on this was the official version of
Marlon history until Willy Tiber gave us
a different version according to him the
great Titan war was intended by helos
and the Tiber x' but by king fritz
even before he inherited the founding
titan King Karl Fritz the 145th King
lamented the LDN empires brutal history
he'd grown tired of the ugly war between
families and countrymen and most of all
his heart ate for Marlay a nation under
constant tyranny when he inherited the
founding tightened he worked with the
Tiber family he offered himself as a way
to bring the history of the LDN empire
to an end
he helped present the Marlon helos as a
hero when the elding's began eliminating
one another as planned the King moved as
many of the LDN people as he could to
the island and enclosed them inside the
walls
he said that anyone who threatened his
peace would be met with countless titans
as retribution but he did not truly mean
that
in fact he passed his own philosophy to
future royal blooded founding Titan
users so that none of them would use the
Titans to destroy the world
apparently King Karl Fritz said the
following if Marlay grows strong and
attempts to take the lives of the royal
family or its founding titan I will
accept it if Marlay decides to
exterminate all LD ends I will accept it
that is how grave the crimes of us
aliens were they could never be
tone for and quote until that eventual
day of retribution came the King wanted
to live inside the walls with his people
and enjoy the brief paradise of a world
without conflict in contrast on the
island traditional history taught people
that it was around 743 seee that all
humans except for the inhabitants of the
island were devoured by Titans around
seven hundred eighty-five see the yamir
we know from the survey Corps was sent
to the island of parody along with her
followers because they were tricked into
joining a cult where your Mir was
presented as a god people worshipped her
like she was the second coming of the
Father your mere friends all of the cult
members including yamir were turned into
Titans yamir would go on to roam around
the island as mindless titan for the
next 60 years 806 seee Risha was born to
LD and parents in the Libero internment
zone 809 C e Griffith sister FEA was
born in the liberia internment Zone 817
c e and eleven-year-old grisha took an
eight-year-old fay outside of the
internment zone walls
Grishka got beaten up by Aaron Kruger
aka Alice punishment while Fay got
killed by the Marlin officer gross 819 C
II Ehren Kruger inherited the attack
titan power 824 C II while working as a
doctor Grishka came into contact with
Grace who told him about the LD and
restorationist and how his sister
actually died Grisha went on to join the
lding group in this group he met Deana
Fritz a woman with royal blood
825 see Grisham married Deana together
they had a son and named him Zeke around
this time within the walls
Herman's father who was a history
teacher told his son that the history
books given by the government were full
of contradictions and mysteries they
were practically no historical records
or stories about what life was like
before the walls in private Irwin's
father shared his theory that when
humanity moved into the walls the king
altered the people's memories to make
them easier to rule everyone shared his
father's theory with others and as a
result the government had the history
teacher killed for getting too close to
the truth 827 C II within the walls the
Royal blooded free Therese was born to
rod Reese and his wife 829 C
in Marley Tom Xavier inherited the beast
Titan power around 829 seee back in the
walls rod Reese's brother uri reese ate
his father and became the new founding
titan kenny Ackerman's grandfather told
him about the history of the Ackermann
clan and why they're persecuted he told
him that Royals fear the Ackerman's
because the power of the Titans cannot
be used to erase their memories and
control them after this Kenny decided to
attack URI
however URI proved to be too powerful
URI apologized for the way the
Ackerman's were treated and can he
decide to join forces with URI becoming
his right-hand man
this partnership put an end to the
persecution of the a current family
later Kenny went to the underground to
visit his sister kucho only to find her
dead however he did find her son a young
Levi and he taught him to fend for
himself before he left him to his own
devices around 830 seee the marlins
decided to gather warriors of marley
from the subject of yamir they gathered
healthy Albion boys and girls from the
ages of 5 to 7 so that they could train
them to become titan warriors morley
wanted the massive amounts of fossil
fuels buried under parody Island at this
point Marley said they had seven Titan
powers in their control but they needed
to Train loyal audience who could use
them because Marlins can't turn into
Titans Grisha was quick to enroll his
young son Zeke into the program hoping
that he would become a double agent like
the owl 832 C II a seven year old Zeke
heard that the Marlins were close to
capturing the LD and restorationist tonk
saber convinced the young Zeke to accuse
his parents so that he could save his
grandparents and maintain his image as a
loyal Marlon warrior the LD
restorationist were sent to the island
of parody where all of them except
Grisha were killed or turned into Titans
that Ehren Kruger transformed killed all
the Marlins present and gave grish of
the attack titan power using the titan
power Grishka made his way to the three
walls where he was discovered by keith
sadhus of the survey corps sadhus help
teach Krishna about human life within
the walls because he believed that
Grisha was suffering from amnesia
between 832 C II and 835 C II many
people in the Chicana dis
came down with a sickness Grisha came up
with a cure and helped heal many people
including the waitress Carla and her
parents while Keith charlotte's became
the commander of the survey Corps and
fought Titans
Grishka married Carla 833 seee Reiner
was born 834 C II and he was born on the
continent while Armand was born within
the walls
835 C e historia the illegitimate
daughter of Rod Reese was born to his
mistress Alma erin was born to Gretchen
Carla and Mikasa was born this year as
well 842 seee
a 15 year old Frieda Reese ate her uncle
Yuri Reese and inherited the founding
Titan on the continent
Zeke inherited the beast Titan power and
Gabby was born 843 cee Reiner inherited
the armored Titan Annie inherited the
female Titan Berthold inherited the
colossal Titan Marcel Galliard inherited
the jaw Titan and Pete inherited the
cart tightening the marlane warriors
used their newly acquired Titan powers
to help defeat an enemy nation for male
while the Marlon Warriors were
undergoing brutal training a kid Aaron
was living a pretty carefree and bored
existence within the walls where he hung
out with his one friend Armin 844 Cee
earlene convinced a notorious thug from
the underground named Levi to join the
survey Corps in the same year Micah's
his parents were killed and she was
kidnapped
Aaron rescued her he gave her his scarf
and brought her home to live with his
family and now we finally arrived to 845
C II the year when our story began
during this year while Maria felt a
ten-year-old Aaron's mostly boring
easygoing life was interrupted by
Berthold Reiner and Annie who traveled
to the island of Paradis and brought
Titans inside the walls Marcel was on
the island too but he was eaten by
Amir's wandering Titan before the team
reached the walls when the walls were
destroyed the Grishka went to see free
Therese he begged her to stop the
attacking Titans when he saw that Frieda
wasn't going to do anything about it he
transformed into the attack Titan and
took her fighting Titan power he passed
on both Titan powers to his son Aaron
Yeager 846 seee Herman's parents tried
to leave the walls in a hot air balloon
and were killed by the first interior
squad 840
seven seee the 104th Training Corps
began while Kenny created the
anti-personnel control squad whose
purpose was supposed to be fighting the
survey Corps but it was actually formed
so he could help Kenny accomplish his
dream of absorbing the founding titan of
course he later figured out that the
powers of the founding titan cannot be
used to their full extent unless one has
royal blood 850 seee 104 training corps
members graduated berthold colossal
titan showed up again and broke through
the outer gate of the trois district a
15 year old Aaron used his attack Titan
power to plug the hole with a boulder
while Annie battled and Reiner made sure
Marko was eaten by a Titan so that he
couldn't revealed that they were
secretly Titan shifters the survey Corps
went on to capture Annie defeat Rod
Reese's giant Titan take burrows
colossal Titan power and temporarily
chase Reiner Peak and Zeke off the
island after they took back she gone
Sheena district they went to Aaron's
basement and found out the truth about
the outside world 851 seee citizens
began to resettle in the shegaon chena
district the survey Corps embarked past
wall Maria for the first time in six
years and made it all the way to the
ocean
Marley sent their first survey fleet to
Paradis Island it was intercepted by the
survey corps the anti Marley and
volunteers who work for Zeke came over
to the survey Corps side and helped them
update their knowledge of the world and
its technology 852 seee Kiyomi Ozma Beto
from the nation of his rule which is
pretty much Japan came to the island she
told me casada that she is the
descendant of huzzah lose lost Lord
meaning that Mika says pretty much like
his little royal
Kiyomi mentioned she is also interested
in the resources that Paradis has to
offer she hopes to make his uru a
powerful nation again and she is willing
to team up with the island for that goal
853 Cee the survey Corps helped to
construct a railway on the island 854
seee
now we've come to the current year in
the manga during this year a 19 year old
Aaron unilaterally decided to infiltrate
an attack Marley he got the Warhammer
Titan power with Nicholas help
however sasha was shot by Gabi during
the retreat
Zeke was taken to the island his real
plan is to make it
so that LD ins can't have children with
Zeke a royal Titan and Aaron who
possesses the founding Titan power they
can actually use the Valentine's true
power however there was a divide between
the Jaeger ist's a rebel faction who
want to reunite the two brothers and the
rest of humanity within the walls some
people including the commander-in-chief
of the three military branches zactly
were killed Arman wants to trust an
Aaron he hopes that he's only using Zeke
to carry out his own plans but he can't
help notice that Aaron has changed for
instance he was cruel to Mikasa and said
he always hated her which was extremely
out of character for him Marley has
attacked the island recently and Aaron
fought off their military and three
Titans long enough for Zeke to arrive
however Zeke was hit and the question
now is whether or not he'll scream and
turn to people who drank his spinal
fluid wine into Titans we are not sure
whether or not Levi is dead at this
point because a thunder spear did go off
in front of him and only hanji verify
that he was dead someone who would have
reason to hide the truth and Gabi the
most brainwashed warrior of all time has
seen the light she realizes now that
there were only people on the island and
no Devils along with Colt and falco
grace she is currently trying to escape
the island but that will get complicated
if falco who ingested some of Zeke's
spinal fluid turns into a Titan so
things are definitely at a boiling point
right now this current year has been the
craziest one yet and I can't wait to see
what happens from here on out and that
is it for today's video we covered over
one thousand eight hundred and fifty
years of attack on titan history in one
video I'm impressed I hope you enjoyed
it and found it useful smash that like
button if you did if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell for more attack on Titan videos so
just future videos in the comments a big
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who helped make these videos
possible I especially want to thank our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh chubs is the man nothing but a
fan and Jason Wilson and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stay on top
all clans baby ray 8:17 ffvp Steven and
Radha al-hola attend Madi Mac 239
and Michael kaldur'ahm if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon comm anime uproar and
becoming a patient today for as little
as $1 if you do so you'll get your name
feature in future videos alongside these
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our patron only discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
if you're interested anyways thanks
again for all your support and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]